Hello world it Saroj and do
you gotta catch them all?
When I say catch 'em all I'm talking
about Pokemon, I've got to catch them all,
but I've also got to train them all.
I've got to train them all.
You can seeing a generative
adversarial network.
What we're going to do in this video is
we're going to generate all new Pokemon.
You heard me correctly,
more than the original 150 shadows to
the original 150 and the 5 billion other
ones that came after that.
But we're going to generate all new
Pokemon using what's called a generative
adversarial network. Now, I've done
this in one or two videos before,
but this is probably going to be the most
clear explanation I've ever done of it.
It's a very popular machine
learning technique popularized
just and created just
two years ago. And uh, this
is going to be awesome.
So this is a demo of what I've already
generated with my Gan Gan for short.
So we'll call them gangs from now on. And
as you can see, it looks pretty funky.
We give it some training images of
real Pokemon. And then after training,
using this generative
adversarial approach,
it's going to be able to generate new
Pokemon that have never existed before.
So let's dive right out right on into it.
At the end,
I'm going to go into the code, but first
let's talk about what these things are.
So there's a lot of different ways that
we can classify the learning process for
computers, right? The
machine learning process,
we could talk about supervised
unsupervised reinforcement learning,
but one of the most popular ways is
discriminative and generative, right?
So for generative models,
we are learning the probability,
the joint probability of x and y.
For discriminative models,
we're living the probability of y given x.
So you might be thinking,
what does that mean? Right?
So here's what it means.
Here's a really simple example
that I found off of stack overflow.
So let's say this is our
training data, right? The,
it's just a four x y value pairs,
right? X, Y, x, y, x, y, x,
Y, and they're all integers. And so the,
the joint probability that
has a probability of x
and y is going to be these
four values. Okay? And
then the probe bill,
the the probability of y given x
is going to be these four values.
So take a second to kind of just stare
at this and eventually you're going to
get it.
But let me help explain.
So let's say let's say y
equals zero and x equals one.
So this top left corner here,
what that means is what is the probability
that y is going to be zero and x is
going to be one out of all
the possible cases. Well, if
we look up here, we'll see,
okay, here's one case, here's
another case. These two are not.
So out of the four possible cases,
two of them are cases where
x is one and wise is zero.
So that's two out of four or one half.
And so that's how it works for
the joint probability for the,
for the probability of y given x,
it's if,
if x is going to be one,
how many times is why going to be zero?
So here's x equals one.
So why zero?
Here's x equals one y zero and
those are the only two times.
So out of all those times
it's going to be zero.
So that's a hundred percent probability,
right?
So what's the probability that you're
going to get zero given every time that x
equals one? Right? So that's the
difference between both of those.
It still doesn't explain the difference,
but that's the mathematical explanation.
So the idea behind generative models
is that we are trying to create these
systems that generate new data
given some training Dataset, right?
So the pros of this are that we have
knowledge about the data distribution.
What that means is any kind of
training data that you have,
any kind of training data,
we can represent all of it
as some distribution, right?
Some curve,
either a Gaussian or a multinomial,
all sorts of distribution and
what a distribution is. It is,
it is a range of possibilities,
right?
It is a range of possibilities
of what some data could be.
And if we learn what that distribution is,
then we can say,
let's take some point on that distribution
and generate some data from it.
What that means is that point,
it doesn't necessarily have to
come from our training Dataset,
but it's a part of the range
of possibilities and thus it,
it can be a novel data point,
meaning a new type of data that looks or
feels very similar to the original data.
Basically we can generate new data if
we learn what the distribution of the
existing data is. The cons of this is that
this is very expensive to learn, right?
Degenerative models in general are harder
to train than discriminative models
and we need lots of data. Discriminative
models, on the other hand,
they don't tell you to generate anything.
They're really easy to use.
That's the pro. The con is that all
they do is they discriminate, right?
They classify, they differentiate.
Given this dog, given this cat,
is this a dog?
Is this a cat?
It tries to put labels on things that
probability of y a label given some input
x, right? So that's why he's
the probability of y given X.
Whereas for the joint probability
it's probability of x and y.
So given some new x,
we can generate a why or given some new
why we can generate an x at the same
time. Right? So that's a difference.
So a lot of times we talk about
discriminative models, um,
and there are a lot of popular ones.
So logistic regression
support vector machines,
neural networks can be discriminative.
That can also be generative as
we're going to see here. Uh,
but for generative models we have naive
Bayes mixture of Gaussians Hidden Markov
models. And if you're curious
about how any of these models work,
I would point you to my math of
intelligence playlist. I have videos,
detailed videos on every single one
of these that you're seeing here.
They're all in my math of
intelligence playlists.
So take some coffee and just go through
that whole playlist if you want to learn
how all these models work.
But my idea right now is to just show
you that there are two types of machine
learning models that we can,
we can, uh, think about, right?
So again,
discriminative models,
probability of y given x and generative
models or the probability of x and y.
And we can use Bayes theorem
to derive that as well.
Discriminative models learned the
boundaries between different classes.
If it learns the boundary, then giving
some new data point, we can say, oh,
it's on the left side. It must be a
dog, or it's, it's on the right side,
it must be a cat.
Whereas generative models learning the
distribution of the clashes and then once
we have that distribution, we can say,
boom, generate this, generate this,
generate this. Okay, so
that's kind of how it works.
So one class of generative models is
the generative adversarial network.
Okay. So the generative
adversarial network at a high
level looks just like this.
Ignore the detective part for now.
But what happens is we have
to neural networks. By the
way, I met Ian Goodfellow,
the Creator, I interviewed him. If
you're curious, just search Saroj.
Ian Goodfellow on Youtube.
Great interview. Anyway,
we have two neural networks here.
We have a generator network and we have
a discriminator network and our job is
going to be this,
right?
We input some random noise
into the generator network.
That is some random group of numbers
of vector and we're going to feed it to
this neural network,
this generator network.
It's job is to take that input
and do it all known. That works.
Do you apply a series of matrix
multiplication to that input?
Until we have an output and that output,
we're going to consider a fake image.
Now the discriminator is gonna say is
only going to look at the real training
dataset that we have.
That is the real,
that are the real images and
once we have these real images,
we'll feed those into the discriminator
network and it's going to output a
probability label,
whether it's real or it's fake because
the discriminator takes two inputs.
It's going to take the real image and
it's going to take the generated fake
image and its job is to say is the
fake image real or fake? Right?
And at first it's going to say,
obviously this is fake.
You just took some random noise
vector and generated an image from it.
It had nothing to do with the
training data. Of course it's fake.
And then what's going to happen
is when it makes that prediction,
we're going to compute an error value
like always. And then what do we do?
We optimize moving forward
and when we optimize,
we are optimizing to minimize
a loss function, right?
And when we minimize a loss function,
we're using a strategy like gradient
descent, right? With gradient descent,
we can compute a great value to
update the weights of both networks,
both the discriminator network
and the generator network.
What that means is they both get
better over time. And what that means,
what that really means is that because
they get both get better over time,
the generator is getting
better at generating very
realistic looking data until
the discriminator cannot decide
what's real and what's fake.
And that's when the generator
has done its job well. Right?
So one way to think about this is that
the discriminator is a detective is
trying to figure out what's
real and what's fake. And
the generator is a forger.
It's trying to say, hey, this is a real
copy of the Mona Lisa, but it's not.
It's a fake copy of the Mona Lisa
and it's just using random noise,
random numbers generated as its input.
And as a tweets are updated,
it's getting better and better at this.
Over time we can think of
the discriminator as a binary
classifier real or fake
one or zero. And, and the way
we can do this is because we,
we ourselves, we as programmers
know what's real and what's fake.
So we can assign those labels
and because we can assign labels,
it's a supervised problem.
And because it's a supervised problem,
what is a technique that we
use? Here we go. Go for it.
Say back propagation, right?
That's how we update our gradients.
We use backpropagation and notice
because we have two networks,
we have two networks.
We are going to be back propagating
gradients for two different networks.
That means we have two
different optimization problems
running simultaneously.
So the model's played two distinct,
literally adversarial roles
because they are our adversaries.
One is trying to fool the other constantly
and the other is trying to not be
fooled. Right? And because we are
using this optimization technique,
they're both getting better and better
over time. So you might be thinking,
okay, this sounds really complicated.
I don't know what this looks like,
but let me tell you this.
There are really only four components.
I know I put five,
but they're really only four components
that think about here you have are the
genuine Dataset, whatever that is,
images, videos, whatever that data set is,
and then you have eye, which is the
random noise vector, which is trying to,
which is the kind of starting point that
the generator uses to generate anything.
You have g the generator and you
have d the discriminator, right?
You know how to build a neural network.
I made a million videos on that.
So you just build two neural networks
and then you have some training Dataset,
you have a loss function and you go,
that's a generative adversarial network.
The end. No, I'm just kidding. There's
more to it than that. There's more to it.
And I'm going to show you,
but first let's talk about the
use cases of this thing, right?
So obviously a generating Pokemon
is a great use case. By the way,
please,
let's just chill with the M and I s.
T I know everybody uses them
and ist as the baseline,
but can we just start using
Pokemon as the new M and ist?
I'm just saying it right now.
Let me drop this right now.
Let's start using Pokemon please.
As the baseline,
the original 150 as the new baseline for
generative models instead of m and ist
because as awesome as young
raccoon is, the guy who, you know,
the godfather of convolutional nets and
his, you know, Dataset m and ISD is,
it's just time to move on to
just to keep things interesting.
I've made a million
videos about him and ist.
I'm not going to rant about it
too much. Anyway, back to this,
we can do so many things with gans.
For example,
we can turn black and white
images to color. We can,
we can turn maps into a digital maps.
We can say we can turn day tonight.
You can make a drawing of a purse and
then turn it into a real purse. Right?
But to get really trippy, you can feed
it a, a plain text, plain English input,
like the flour is white and pink in
color with pedals that have veins.
And then it's going to
generate images from that text.
Extrapolate for a second here. What that
means is as these things get better,
we can feed them, not just texts of,
you know, pretty little flower images.
We can say, design me a rocket,
design me, forget a rocket.
Design me the particle
accelerator from Cern, you know,
that $50 billion machine under
Geneva designed that for me.
Here are all the specs.
Here's all the data go.
What that means is the cost of the barrier
to entry to a million things becomes
possible. Design, you know,
anything, a living group design,
clearly there's a lot of possibilities
for design and engineering, right?
Three d modeling. But it's not
just that, it's also for science.
So these researchers that in
Silico medicine said, let's, uh,
let's generate a new drug
using, uh, using Gantz.
So the goal was to train the generator
to sample drug candidates for given
disease as precisely as possible to
existing drugs from a drug database.
Right?
And so what happens is after training,
it was possible for them to generate a
drug for a previously incurable disease
using the generator and
using the discriminator to
determine whether the sample
drug actually cures the given disease.
So there are a lot of use cases for this,
and it's not just that there
are a lot of use cases,
there are a lot of gans fantastic
gans and where to find them.
That's a great blog post by the way.
There are so many different types
of gangs out there, seriously,
but one huge improvement to the
initial Gann paper in 2014 is the deep
convolutional Gan or DC Gan. And so
the, the, the main difference here,
the main main difference is that instead
of using feedforward networks as both
the generator ended discriminator,
they used a convolutional network as the
generator and a d convolutional network
as the discriminator. So that's just
a convolutional network flipped.
And what happened is they made
a few important discoveries.
One important discovery was batch
normalization is a must for both networks.
Fully kind of fully hidden, connected
layers. Not a good idea. Avoid pooling.
Simply stride. You're
convolutions. So again,
pooling recall from my video
about capsule networks.
Hinton the godfather of
neural networks themselves.
He's also skeptical of pooling.
In fact,
he replaced it with that capsule strategy.
So here's a great research idea for you.
Apply capital networks to generative
adversarial networks. Boom, take it,
run with that. Be the
first to do that. Okay.
Capsule generative adversarial networks.
Paper of the year award right there.
Paper of the year award. Uh, right.
So relu activations are your
friend almost always. Why?
Because it prevents the vanishing gradient
problem. Exactly. If you didn't say it,
that's okay.
Vanilla Gans can work on simple data sets,
but DC gans are far better. And if you
have some new state of the art algorithm,
compare it with the baseline
of using a DC Gan. Another one,
conditional gans. Now these are
really interesting because notice,
remember that image I showed you where
it said, here's a flower with petals.
It's white. It's pretty generated. They
use the conditional again to do that.
What that means is what we're feeding
into the generator is not just some noise.
We're also feeding in these strings
were were conditioning the data on these
extra strings like male, black
hair, blonde makeup, whatever.
And we're also conditioning the
discriminator on this as well.
And what happens is we are
feeding both as vectors, right?
So we're converting those strings
into numbers vectorizing them,
we're converting the noise,
two vectors.
We're concatenating both vectors and
feeding that in his input into the
generator as well as a discriminator.
And when we back propagate,
when we update our weights,
the networks are going to be more suited
to generate data or discriminate data
that is conditioned on those
strings because there's a,
there's an association between those
strings and the training images because we
have to pre label them,
right?
We have to pre labeled the images with
these strengths and because it's learning,
uh, to generate and discriminate
conditioned on these strings,
we can input these strings as,
as the sole input after training.
And then there's going to be able to
generate images like wipe pretty flower or
whatever, which is very cool. Uh, lastly,
there's one more type of Gan of the many,
many guns out there that I want to talk
about. That is a very important, again,
it's called the
Wasserstein or Wasserstein,
however you want to say Gan
or w again and the, the dif,
the real discovery of w Ganz was that if
you've ever tried to train again before
and you should after this video, if you
haven't, do it, do it. If you haven't,
it'll be great. You'll learn
a lot. Trust me. Uh, the,
the great thing about [inaudible] is
that it improved the, the loss function.
So if you look at a general,
again, like a generic vanilla Gan,
this is what the loss function looks like,
or even a DC Gan.
How do you know when to stop training?
Right? How do you know when it's,
when it should be done? Usually this is,
this is a really ugly a loss function.
There's, there's no idea. Uh, there's
no way to tell when to stop training.
You just have to guess and check.
So this looks much prettier.
Right now we know when to stop training,
when that loss is maybe at
the 500,000 iteration mark.
Now that loss is pretty low and everything
training afterward is going to lead
to diminishing results.
So that's what w gans do.
They replace the loss function,
which is normally called the Jensen
Shannon divergence with instead the
Wasserstein distance. They tried to
minimize the Wasserstein distance.
So I can go into that,
but that's a lot for one video,
but that's at a high level of
what it is, right? So that's,
that's more of the state of the art
when it comes to Gantz. Okay. So, um,
that's that. Now let's talk
about the code. Okay, let's,
let's go into the code now for this
Pokemon gap. Let's take a look at it.
So this code is about 285 lines.
So it's a lot,
but it's not too much, right? We, we
can fit it all into a single class file.
And I've, it's built with tensorflow.
Okay. It's built with tensorflow.
So the training data, is this right?
These are all Pokemon images right here,
right? We've got several Pokemon.
It's not just the original hundred 50.
We got a lot of them.
Don't trio, whatever.
I only know the original one 50 because
when I was a kid, that's, that's all we,
uh, which one was this? Ticklet.
Tigger. I don't know. Anyway, no,
I know it's not ticker. It's, I forgot
the name. Anyway, let's look at this.
A python file. Okay.
We get ready for this.
So we have a processing data
function that we can just skip.
Basically what that does is
it just formats all those
images into the same size
because we want all those images to be
the same size when we feed it into our
networks, right? Because that's,
that's called, that's the,
that's the vectorization process.
So we have two functions.
Each of these functions
represents one of the networks.
We have a generator function,
and then we have a discriminator function.
So don't get afraid by looking at this.
This is just standard tensorflow code.
If we wanted to, we could,
we could have used care Ross,
and this all could have been
abstracted to 10 or 12 lines,
but we want to be very specific about
what the details are of what this looks
like. So remember with convolutions
convolutional networks, this,
this Gan, by the way, is, is a w GAM.
So what that means is it's a DC Gan.
That means today,
convolutional and a deep convolutional
network for the generator and the
discriminator respectively.
And for the loss function,
it's minimizing the Wasserstein distance
and therefore that makes it a w Gan,
right?
And so for the generator,
we have art convolutional
network that we can see here.
Now for convolutional networks, we
have blocks, I call them blocks, right?
So convolution bias activation.
And then we repeat,
that's one block convolution
bias activation repeat.
Now a lot of times we have pooling and
that's considered in a block and we
repeat that,
but not in this case because for DC gans,
they found pooling was not a good thing.
So we have a convolutional layer,
we have a bias, and then we have an
activation function, which is Relu, right?
And then we just repeat that over and
over again. Convolution activation, bias,
repeat convolution, convolution
bias, activation, repeat.
And we do that for five or no,
six layers. So it's a sixth layer,
convolutional network, and that
is our generator. And at the very,
very end we have this 10 h function
that's going to squash the output and then
we return the outputs of that.
Okay, so that's for the generator.
Now for the discriminator,
we just flip it, right? It's,
it's flipped the other way because
we are trying to discriminate,
given an image as input.
What is the output probability,
what that image is real or fake. So
we say convolution activation, bias,
repeat.
And tensorflow has these functions for
each of these operations that are apart
of convolutional networks. Thank you
tensorflow. So then we do it again.
Convolution activation bias, repeat
convolution activation, bias, repeat.
And we do that for four layers, and
at the very end, at the very end,
at the very end,
we use a sigmoid to squash the outputs
and then return the probability values
for real or fake.
Okay?
So those are our functions for the both
the generator and the discriminator.
Now in our training loop, it
looks like this. We say, okay,
well we have placeholders
and remember intenser flow,
we are building a computation
graph that is a graph of where,
where data flows through, where
the tensors flow through, right?
So a computation graph, you can think of
a neural network as a computation graph.
You can think of a neural
network has a function, right?
It's a glorified function. And so
it's a set up operations, right?
So we'll create placeholders in
the placeholders are gateways,
they're the gateways through which we
input data into the computation graph.
So what is the type of data
that we're going to input?
What we're going to input some
image from our training dataset.
We're going to input some random
vector for the generator, right?
So we need to create placeholders for
both the real image. And the random input,
then we'll have a boolean value just
to say, should we train it or not?
That's just for us.
Now we can say,
take our generator and feed. It has its
parameters, the random input, right?
So we're feeding it a
random inputs with the,
with the random dimension of that
input, and then we're going to say, yes,
let's train it and it's going
to output a fake image, right?
It has nothing to do with the
training data sets, right?
It's only going to learn
to morph, morph that, uh,
input into,
it's only going to learn to morph that
initial random input into something that
looks like the training data
because of the optimization scheme,
which is backpropagation correct?
So we're going to,
we're going to output a fake image.
And then for the discriminator,
we give it the real image rights and
it's going to output the real result.
We're also going to give the discriminator
the fake image and it's going to
output the fake results so
that the probabilities of both,
and we're going to use those,
the difference between the fake result
and the real result as our loss for the
discriminator to update that.
And for our generator,
it's going to be the fake result.
Okay?
So remember there are two
distinct different optimization
schemes happening at
the same time as these networks
are adversaries of each other.
And we're going to use the,
uh,
and we're going to use the rms prop a
optimizer for both of them to optimize
both to rms. Prop is a type of
gradient descent. Okay? There's,
I also have a video on all the different
types of gradient descent out there.
It's called which activation
function should you use?
Saroj search that on Youtube.
Okay.
So we have two distinct optimization
schemes great into San for both of them,
Aka backpropagation. And then we
have a bunch of, uh, you know,
check point in restore variables,
all kind of boiler plates.
And then let's get to the good
stuff, our training loop, right?
So in our training loop we're going to
stay for a number of epochs and for our
batch size that we predefined
for given number of iterations,
let's update the discriminator and then
we'll update the generator and to update
them.
What we mean is that what we mean is we
have a tensor flow session and inside
the session the graph is initialized.
We'll,
we'll feed it both the trainer and
the loss function has, we'll feed it,
will feed it the training noise and
the training image, right? For the,
for the discriminator and
for the generator we're going
to feed it the training,
the training noise for the random input.
And so we feel when we feed both of those
in and we are, and we're also saying,
well we know we want to
optimize both using this,
it's going to optimize both given both
of those distinct inputs at the very end
we can check point and save our
model every 500 epochs and that's it.
And then I also have this testing
function here that I've commented out,
but if you want to test it after training,
which you should then go ahead and comment
that out and then you can start Jen,
that's how you're going to start
generating the Pokemon after you're done
training. So I also want to say, do not,
do not attempt to train
this thing on your Puny Cpu,
on your Mac book or whatever
you have. Um, I, I tried,
it's going to take, you know, 24 to 48
hours. If you try to train on a CPU,
use Amazon [inaudible], use
Floyd hub, use Google cloud.
You can get free credits for this,
for a free trial, but use a GPU.
It's a hundred x plus
times faster than the CPU.
Deep learning is meant to be run on a GPU,
unless of course you have a
deep learning machine, right?
But train this thing on a GPU and
you can do it in three to five hour.
If you like this video,
please hit the subscribe button.
And for now I've got to go find more
gans to train. So thanks for watching.